on soir genre bonjour merci d'être avec
nous clairement nous sommes à un moment
charnière et clé de ce procès absolument
je crois que les shsh des images sont
choquantes mais je pense qu'il faut bien
garder à l'esprit que le tribunal
l'audience ne procède devra démontrer si
oui ou non le les actes perpétrés par
des règles chauvin sont directement rue
pour conséquence de tuer georges flotte
parce que il ne nous aura pas échappé
que l'accusé plaide non coupable
c'est à dire qu'il prétend que les actes
l'acte accompli non l'a été dans le
cadre d'une procédure policière normale
et qu'en réalité chaud georges floyd ne
serait décédée que pour des raisons
extérieures à son acte de l'autre côté
l'accusation devra pour sa part faire la
preuve contraire donc on voit bien qu'il
ya deux aspects dans ce procès tout
d'abord l'aspect purement juridique et
c'est vrai qu'il y aura une bataille
l'accusé de la défense va faire valoir
un certain nombre de rapports de la part
de ses propres experts vous savez qu aux
etats unis
il y a les experts du procureur mais la
défense peut avoir ses propres experts
dont qu il y aura une bataille
d'expertisé médicale une expertise plus
membres une bataille autour de l'
expertise médicale ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point qui est
important à supposer même et là encore
laissons faire le procès à supposer que
chauvin soit condamné et bien je pense
que ce qui sera aussi important ça sera
là
la sanction qui sera prononcé et ce sont
ces deux éléments qui seront
particulièrement importants enfin je
dirais que c'est un procès
particulièrement sensible vous savez moi
je pense que la dernière fois que j'ai
vu un procès sur le plan sociologique
sur le plan social et politique aussi
sensible c'était il y a plus de plus de
plus de 25 ans parce qu'effectivement
les questions est non raciale sont
tellement prégnante aux états unis que
le moindre la mode histoire de ce genre
peut faire éclater
là éclater les supporters des heures où
les supporters des autres que ça
pourrait donner d'autres drames gens te
beaux jours vous le soulignez très bien
ce procès il est éminemment politique
d'ailleurs joe biden ne lui même annoncé
qu'il allait le suivre de très près ce
procès qu'elle peut être un bon verdict
y en at il un possible je crois tout
d'abord oui c'est un procès qui sera qui
est particulièrement suivie vous savez
qu'on peu baba quand on regarde on
visionne les les séances le chauve à une
petite équipe d'avocats en face vous
avez véritablement des personnalités qui
sont qui sont présentes il ya évidemment
le procureur de l'état mais il ya un
avocat particulièrement célèbre qui est
ancien solicitors d'obama qui est venue
de deux rois chine tonnes qui va être ou
qui sera au nombre des coûts conseil qui
est un homme extrêmement intelligent qui
a remporté un certain nombre de
procédures devant la cour suprême des
etats-unis donc on voit bien qu'ils
aient un poids à la fois intellectuel
juridique mais un poids politique parce
que joe biden a fait sa campagne sur la
réconciliation de l'amérique il avis il
a été présent pendant les événements
liés à la sphère flingue
donc il est évident que la communauté
noire pas simplement la communauté noire
mais d'une manière générale les
minorités l'attend en quelque sorte aux
hôtes ou attentes le résultat de ce
procès ait eu au tournant et donc de
fait joe biden est attendu également au
tournant il ne faudrait pas que cette
histoire deraa alors quel verdict
vous savez on a vu les images de mon
point de vue il ya peu de chances que
chauvin soient acquittés de mon point de
vue mais nous sommes loin du résultat ce
qui pour moi un sera important c'est la
sanction parce qu'il est évident que la
sanction qui sera infligée
de risque d'être un message en tout cas
c'est comme ça que la communauté noire
américaine ne prendra sera un message
pour les la famille des victimes et dans
la communauté afro américaine mais pas
seulement parce que la sphère djordje
floyd est allé bien au delà de la
communauté afro américaine
c'est véritablement le rapport entre la
police et le net-citoyen américain enfin
je pense que probablement les policiers
américains eux mêmes qui dans leur
grande majorité font correctement leur
travail et bien doit probablement avec
une certaine tension ils attendent avec
un peu de d'anxiété ce résultat parce
qu'ils ont peur également que cette
affaire ne fasse trop tard juive sur
l'ensemble de la police et donc je pense
que chacun a en tête de se débarrasser
au plus vite dans terminer je dirai non
pas de se débarrasser mais d'en terminer
de ce procès est-ce que ferment ça va
être le procès d'un système plus que
celui d'un homme
je le crains je le crains pour les
raisons que l'on convient d'évoquer
c'est pour ça que je sais qu'il ya une
dimension juridique vrai dans tous les
procès mais il ya aussi la dimension
politique
là le le rapport comme notaire pas
seulement mais aussi les discriminations
qu'elles ont pu assister parce que on ne
rappellera pas les chiffres mais c'est
vrai que la communauté afro-américaine
et tant en terme de deux niveaux
d'égalité bien en deçà de 2 c d autres
citoyens américains
il ya une véritable revendication dans
une amérique qui finalement n'a pas
complètement qui est loin d'avoir pansé
les plaies de la ségrégation
c'est tout le problème de la société
américaine qui de surcroît est de plus
en plus polarisé
donc on voit bien que c'est bloc contre
bloc et c'est donc inévitablement le
procès de blague la société du de
l'histoire américaine et de cette
amérique qui a vraiment du mal à se
réconcilier avec son passé qui a du mal
à faire le contre
le l'histoire des stages la ségrégation
et puis une amérique du 21e siècle je
pense que c'est oui c'est véritablement
le souci et on voit difficilement
comment les choses pourraient être
résolu très rapidement parce que on a eu
l'occasion de dire sur vos antennes la
solution ne viendra pas seulement d'un
procès la solution du viendra de
politiques publiques qui doivent être
mises en place pour assurer à la fois le
le le rattrapage de cette communauté et
puis plus généralement qu'il y à une
sorte de réconciliation entre l'amérique
toute entière et ça malheureusement on
n'y prend pas complètement le chemin
merci beaucoup jean-claude beaujour je
rappelle que vous êtes un vice président
du cercle de réflexion en france
amérique est également avocat en droit
international merci à vous